welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and spoilers for Ant-Man 3 but Kang is
not deceased Kenya's not dead ladies and
gentlemen because like a crazy old man
in the middle of the street I am here to
tell you that the end times are near for
the second coming of Kang is upon us all
in the Multiverse might not ever be the
same because as of the end of
quantumania Kane the Concorde may have
ascended into becoming more than just a
man just like he did one time in the
Marvel Comics so stick with me and find
out just how he did this my nerd babies
but anyways like always be sure to head
on over to nerdrion.shop to check out
our incredible selection of nerd gear
for you and the people that you love we
got a lot of cool stuff inspired by
Ant-Man The Lost quantumania and the
last of us so check out nerd riot.shop
today alright so like I said up top I do
not think that King the Conqueror died
in Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania when
he got sucked into his weird Quantum
energy core like some type of
poltergeist in Luigi's Mansion or
Ghostbusters one two and three and four
I believe he just lost his corporeal
form and became something new something
no longer human a being of pure Quantum
energy something that Marvel Comics
defines as a Quantum temporal wave in
what if number 39 from 1992. the very
issue that introduces the concept of a
Quantum wave version of Kang that
threatened the entire Multiverse and the
threat that the TVA took especially
seriously and even needed the Watcher to
break his oath of non-interference to
help with because you see working as an
agent of the timekeepers in this time
Quake storyline in the what if Comics
the Kang variant called immortus ends up
absorbing enough Nexus energy from Nexus
beings across the Multiverse and
cosmically ascends from being a mere
mortal man into a non-corporeal Quantum
wave with the power to rearrange the
entire structure of the Multiverse
timelines at will and I believe that
this is exactly what happened to Kang at
the end of quantumania after Scott Lang
shoved a combination of free red
shrinking energy discs and three blue
glowing energy discs into Kang's yellow
Quantum energy core creating a massively
unstable orange glowing radioactive
reaction that hope pushes Kang into
before Kang gets sucked into it however
after Kang is sucked into this orange
energy Vortex the quantum core explodes
releasing a massive wave of quantum
energy that sweeps over both Scott and
hope and then spreads outward from
Kang's headquarters before imploding
back in again so while Scott did succeed
in stopping Kane from leaving the
quantum realm as a physical man I don't
think that Scott succeeded in stopping
Kang from leaving the quantum realm as
orange Quantum temporal wave energy or
in Loki TVA terms a sentient temporal
Aura man possibly even hiding and
hitching a ride inside of Scott and or
Hope's bodies as well because that wave
went right through them and I believe
that this is the case because
historically the MCU has shown time and
time again that a human body is not 100
necessary for a person to exist bodies
are just useful to have to interact with
physical things because human beings in
the MCU are more than just their bodies
Prime examples including Zola from cap2
and what if najma and the clandestine
energy beings from Miss Marvel the
eternals electro Mark and Stephen in the
duot afterlife and Moon Knight The
ancestral plain ego the Supreme
intelligence Vision the living mind
Stone energy man in a vibranium body hex
Vision Billy and Tommy from wandervision
the dark hold Souls of the Damned from
Doctor Strange 2 Odin Jane Foster and
the heroes of Valhalla and most
suspiciously my mysterious ex-wife Miss
minutes who is always up to no good and
is behind on several alimony payments
this is because all beings in the MCU
are more than just physical matter
because Loki season 1 and chongqi taught
us that there is a rainbow of infinity
energy living inside of every person on
Earth and that energy is essentially
their life force and very likely the
reason why beings have marvelous
superpowers in the MCU I believe that
superpowered beans in the MCU tap into
their own inner temporal Infinity energy
inside with the human brand of temporal
Aura energy appearing as a rainbow in
some people after Thanos and Tony both
released two massive surges of rainbow
energy onto the planet with their snaps
in both Infinity war and endgame when
Thanos snapped his fingers Earth became
Ground Zero for a power surge of
ridiculously Cosmic proportions no one's
ever seen anything like it but anyways
this being said I believe that by having
his body destroyed by this machine Kane
will be able to have the power to get
his revenge on the Council of Kings for
exiling him by destroying their beloved
organized Multiverse structure of secret
timelines that they've built as this
Quantum wave being and seeing how
something about the energy from Kang's
energy core caused a probability storm
that allowed Scott to create hundreds of
clones of himself King becoming a living
Quantum wave could very well allow him
to do the same thing in his own way and
basically give Kang the gift that he's
always wanted an infinite Army of cane
clones the that are exactly as vengeful
as him and have his exact mission
objectives unlike all the different
varying types of kings that the Council
of Kings have because if you think about
it if a Quantum wave Kang is going to
fight an infinite amount of immortus
Council of kings that have stopped him
before he's probably going to need
something that he didn't have before his
own Kang Clone Army and if you think
about it this would essentially be what
the other sentient orange energy being
Miss minutes does with the tva's police
force Army of human Souls something that
I went into recently in my video
explaining the Sinister secrets of the
tva's orange power source which I highly
recommend you guys checking out after
this video because it's very interesting
especially after quantumania there is
something about orange Soul Energy power
in the MCU that has the power to affect
timeline and I suspect that Kang's
supposed demise in quantumania is only
the beginning for his plans for Conquest
in the MCU like literally get ready for
Kang the living Quantum wave to bring a
Time Quake to the MCU a Time Quake that
we might just see come into play in the
Marvels with The Disappearance of the
mysterious high-flying Alouette a hero
of both Monica Rambo and Carol Danvers
that I predicted to be the mcu's version
of Blue Marvel in another recent video
huge Rumble throughout the cosmos shook
the Moon and the Sun and the stars in
the sky
a while away flew up throughout the
night
but yeah that is what I believe happens
to Kang at the end of Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania he is not dead he has
become something more and a huge threat
to the Multiverse and the Council of
kings and again check out the time Quake
storyline for the Marvel Comics and what
if 35 to 39 from 1992. if you want to
see more information but anyways thank
you guys so much for watching this video
you can follow me at Mass retainment on
Twitter if you want to see me tweet some
weird [__] and some really fun theories
about the Marvel trigger Theory hashtag
the Marvel trigger Theory but more
importantly you can follow the Rock
shows wherever we are on the social
medias especially on our new channel
called The Deep dive some really great
stuff there where Eric recently went
into breaking down my favorite movie of
all time everything everywhere all at
once with Michelle yo and that brilliant
cast of beautiful beautiful people or
you can just hit up nerd and riot.shop
to pick up one of these amazing new
quantumania hoodies or one of our other
shirts and other stuff inspired by
quantumania and Marvel in general we got
a lot of cool stuff for you and it's a
great way to support the channel but
anyways thank you guys again for
watching I love you guys so much I'll
see you guys next time bye
thank you
[Music]